what's the point of being a badass
fighter if you're not dressed for the
occasion well thanks to the dedication
of Street Fighter fans you can now
choose your wardrobe accordingly as
they've discovered several new character
costumes for the upcoming street fighter
5 i'm lucy and welcome to this
well-dressed gamespot news update play
it up data mined the latest street
fighter 5 beta updates to uncover a
bunch of new costumes as spotted by
polygon reddit user are kafirs voice
posted a video to the site showcasing
each of the new costumes in action check
out their channel for the full video we
can also see the exclusive preorder
battle costume outfits for chun-li and
Ryu in action players can obtain
SHINee's battle costume by pre-ordering
the game on the playstation store or on
pc and reuse battle costume by
pre-ordering at gamestop and would you
look at that Interpol officer shouldn't
Lee is finally getting in police outfits
they say dress for the job you want not
the job you have but I don't think that
works in law enforcement street fighter
5 launches on februari 16th in North
America and Europe for playstation 4 and
PC and I'll be cross-play between the
two platforms so what do you make of the
new outfits could you care less about
what your fighters wear or do you want
them dressed to the nines be sure to let
me know in the comments box below or
come find me on Twitter I'm LEC James
games for all the latest on street
fighter 5 make sure to keep it gamespot